[Music]
you may have noticed that marxism is on
the rise again that's kind of a shocker
in the aftermath of the fall of the
soviet union there was a going theory
the theory was that we had reached the
end of history
that from here on in it was basically
going to be liberalism and
laissez-faire economics that the fall of
the soviet union had definitively shown
that the end of government
redistributionism and centralization
had come that obviously was untrue
because it turns out that the pitch of
marxism
in the end is not really a pitch about
efficacy or utilitarianism it's not
about making you wealthier or making you
happier it's about changing the nature
of man
the basic idea of marxism the basic idea
of socialism is that human beings are
inherently good
and the only thing that wrecks that
inherent goodness is the systems around
us so when we see bad things happening
when we see inequality when we see
cruelty when we see crime that is all a
result of the evil capitalist system
in which we are plunged so if we just
change that if we just destroy the
entire system and replace it with
something
quote unquote fairer if we get all of
our rights from government as opposed to
god
if we stop worrying so much about
individual fate and start worrying a lot
more
about our community as a whole then life
will be better now wherever it's been
tried communism has been a failure
and whatever socialism is tried it has
only been a success to the extent
that capitalism supports it when you
look at democratic socialist countries
in northern europe for example it is
perfectly obvious that these
are capitalist countries with some
social welfare policies however
the rise of marxist theory anew i mean
pure
uncut marxist theory the idea that
income inequality
is in essence immoral and exploitation
the idea
that free market economics is again
exploitation the basic notion that free
exchange is somehow a violation of
personal rights
that is on the rise that's why you've
seen the rise of the squad and the
democratic party it's why you've seen
the rise of bernie sanders
who doesn't really advocate for a
denmark-style system
he more likes the centralized government
systems of open
communist systems even praising those
for literally decades
now the fact is that the rights-based
system of the united states is a good
system
capitalism free markets they're not just
effective they are moral
they're based on the principle that you
are an individual human being and that
your labor belongs to you
that you have the right to alienate that
labor voluntarily that it requires your
consent
to remove that which belongs to you from
you and that the best thing that can
happen for the world is for people to
engage
in mutual exchanges because the bottom
line when it comes to socialism is
i'm here i'm breathing give me stuff the
bottom line of capitalism is
i'm not going to get anything from you
unless i give something to you that free
exchange makes the world a better place
it leads to technological development
it leads to prosperity a part of what's
happening here is that so many americans
believe that they hit a triple when in
reality they were born on third base
meaning that all of the prosperity
they've been experiencing is the result
of a system they now decry
they tend to pretend that prosperity is
the natural state of man
that being rich being powerful being
free all of these things are just how
the world works and so if we
chip away at the foundations of our
society everything will be fine that
isn't true not only is it not true it's
immoral
personal responsibility lies at the root
of capitalism systemic responsibility
lies at the root of socialism
there's only one problem socialism is
not only immoral it is ineffective
and yet the slogans of marxism have
become ever more popular well this week
we're bringing you the best moments from
the last two years of the show with
unique perspectives surrounding a topic
and some of my own reflections on the
collection this week we're looking at
the distortion
of the terms capitalism opportunity and
hard work in favor of socialism
free money and a desire for coddling
from the government we'll jump right
into it with peter robinson on the
communist threats of yesteryear
but first let's talk about a simple
thing that everybody should buy i'm
talking of course about life insurance
i mean there's a lot of stuff going on
in the world that makes you think about
life insurance is it possible to buy it
it is it's still easy to shop for life
insurance right this moment if you have
loved ones depending on your income
you probably should it is the
responsible thing to do the last thing
they need to deal with if god forbid
something happens to you is loss of
income beyond the obvious tragedy
right now you could save 1500 bucks or
more a year by using policy genius to
compare life insurance policies
when you're shopping for a policy that
could last for a decade or more those
savings really do start to add up
what's policy genius well it's an
insurance marketplace built and backed
by a team of industry experts
here's how it works step one you head to
policygenius.com
in minutes you can work out how much
coverage you need and compare quotes
from top insurers to find your best
price
step two apply for the lowest price and
step three policy genius handles the
rest policy genius works for you not the
insurance company if you hit any speed
bumps during the application
process they'll take care of everything
for you they even have policies that
allow eligible customers to skip that
in-person medical exam
and do it over the phone which is super
convenient these days so if you need
life insurance head on over to
policygenius.com right now to get
started it could save 1500 bucks or more
a year by comparing quotes on their
marketplace policy genius when it comes
to insurance it's nice to get it right
let's start with a man who literally
faced communism head on
peter robinson was the chief
speechwriter to then vice president
george h.w bush from 1982 to 1983
and then special assistant and
speechwriter to president ronald reagan
from 1983 to 1988.
it was peter who wrote the address from
reagan in berlin in 1987
that called for general secretary
mikhail gorbachev to tear down this wall
which at the time was incredibly
controversial during his six years at
the white house
peter wrote 300 speeches for the last
two decades he has hosted uncommon
knowledge with peter robinson
at the hoover institution where he has
interviewed an enormous number of
political leaders
writers and thinkers over the years he's
authored books including how ronald
reagan changed my life and
it's my party a republican's messy love
affair with the gop
and has been published in the new york
times wall street journal and many
others when peter robinson found out
that he was going to be featured on the
sunday special again
he sent us this letter the united states
of america as a miracle
free democratic enterprising and one
country to which millions of the rich
and the poor alike
on every continent on the planet dream
of moving
that's the themes which ben and i kept
returning when we recorded this
conversation several months ago
what has happened since bennett's
published a book entitled ironically of
course
how to destroy america in three easy
steps and the democratic party
failing as usual to display any sense of
humor has adopted a platform that takes
him up on the suggestion
as ben knows as michael knowles and drew
clavin and all students of history know
america has always been a close run
thing the revolution might have failed
the civil war might have ended in a
stalemate instead of a victory for the
union
the cold war might have continued for
decade after decade the soviet union
steadily expanding its influence
in the 1990s and beyond as it did during
the 1970s
none of these things happen for one
reason in each generation americans
not all americans but enough recognized
what was at stake
remain true to their principles stood
their ground and fought
now it's our turn that's inspiring stuff
from peter robinson
interviewing peter was just an absolute
thrill and an absolute
pleasure he's a tremendous historian his
his breadth and range of knowledge is
incredible and of course
he is himself a part of history a key
cog in the wheel that led to the fall
of the soviet union the actual evil
empire in episode 75 peter and i talk
about whether americans can unite
without an existential threat like
communism facing us
and the tension of not having a shared
view of american history
but first peter tells me the story
behind writing that tear down this wall
line
in reagan's historic speech mr gorbachev
tear down this wall
[Applause]
1987 spring of 1987 uh
berlin is celebrating some 800th
anniversary gorbachev is going to visit
the queen of england is going to visit
and the west german government
remember was west germany and east
germany in those days the west german
government asked
president reagan to make a visit i got
to sign the speech
and flew to berlin before this would be
six weeks or so before the president was
to speak there
to do some research i went to the wall i
went to the place where the president
was going to be delivering
the speech it's all gone now but the
wall was there
the reichstag which was still packed
with
shell uh case shell marks from the
bombing this
at the final battle of berlin and behind
it me was west berlin modern city
color life movement recent model cars
and then you look over the wall
and there was almost no motion guards
marching back and forth
it was as though the color had been
leached out of it everything was gray
brown the buildings even looked
dilapidated so there was
this was a place where you could feel
the weight of
of history communism there
capitalism here this was the place where
the soviet advance stopped
at the end of the second world war this
was the place where the americans
and the the british had had taken over
so at that moment i was a young
speechwriter in trouble because what
could i
write that would equal what you felt
there the felt weight of history
several other stops in berlin including
one to the ranking american diplomat who
is full of ideas about what ronald
reagan should
not say west berlin is surrounded by
east germany
the people who live here are very
sensitive to the nuance and subtlety
involved
necessary for east-west relations don't
have ronald reagan sound like an
anti-communist cowboy
and by the way don't have them make a
big deal about the wall they've all
gotten used to it
and that evening i went to a dinner
party
uh west berliners whom i had not met but
we had mutual friends back in washington
and so they put together a sort of a
buffet
for me 15 or so people different walks
of life
a professor a couple of students and my
host and hostess were lovely retired
people
he had worked at the world bank in
washington and retired back to west
berlin
and i asked the question i said i've
been told by the american diplomat that
you've all gotten used to the wall by
now
and there was a silence and i thought
i've made just the gaffe that the
diplomat
doesn't want ronald reagan to make but
then one man
raised his arm and pointed and said my
sister lives just a few kilometers in
that direction
but i haven't seen her in more than 20
years how do you think we feel about
that wall
and they went around the room they'd
stopped talking about it
they had not stopped caring about it
they had not stopped
hating it and each person told one man
talked about walking to work each
morning and each morning he would walk
under a guard tower
where there was an east german soldier
with a rifle
over his shoulder who would peer down at
him with binoculars
and the man said we share the same
history we speak the same language but
one of us is a zookeeper
and the other is an animal and i have
never been able to decide which was
which
and then our hostess a lovely woman
called ingeborg elves who just died a
couple of years ago
she must have been younger than i am now
she was in her
perhaps in her early 50s
she was a very gracious woman she'd been
charming throughout the dinner party
but now she became angry and she said if
this man gorbachev she
smacked her made a ball of one fist and
smacked it into the palm of her
of her other hand if this man gorbachev
is serious
with this glasnost this perestroika he
can prove it
by coming here and getting rid of that
wall
and that went into my notebook because
the moment
she said that i knew that if ronald
reagan had been there in my place
he would have responded to that remark
the simplicity the dignity
and the power of that remark so the
answer that's a long way around to get
to the answer to your question but the
if the question is where did that phrase
come from
the answer is it started with a german
woman
who lived behind the wall herself
and somebody who was five when the
berlin wall speech
was was spoken yeah the the impression
that was left in the aftermath of the
fall of the berlin wall the end of the
communist regime in the ussr is that it
was the end of history that now
everybody was friends again i mean even
if you watch terminator 2 you have
characters saying to each other why do
the russians have missiles pointed at us
we're we're friends now
and there's this great feeling that
arises in america that basically
it's all over and it seems as though
we've sort of turned our guns on each
other as opposed to
the existential threat that used to
exist out there maybe that was
temporarily lifted for a brief moment in
time after september 11th
but we're certainly back at it to an
excessive degree right now
do you think that americans have enough
in common now to actually hold each
other
to to see each other as non-enemies in
the absence
of an existential threat like the soviet
union i do
i do believe so i also believe we have
to work
at what we have in common so
i'm trying to say something i'm trying
to put this in a way that
gives it some sort of edge or some sort
of some sort of interest because this is
the kind of thing that you say on the
radio
every single day and god bless you for
saying it but i didn't come here just to
agree with you
on the other hand i will identity
politics
the politics of of dividing americans
that's not only wrong it's it that
approaches in my mind that's
that comes close to a kind of wickedness
because why is it
think about this
immigration is a problem we have to
addre blah blah blah all that is true
but why is it that a mexican who just
crosses that border within a few months
finds himself or
in a position to better the lot of his
not just his family but his village back
in mexico what is it about this country
that permits
remittances back to mexico of almost 30
billion
dollars a year why is it
that one of the first things that
chinese do
chinese the chinese who since 1979 when
deng xiaoping had his opening to markets
and now there are lots of people in
china who are rich
what do they do they try to buy real
estate right here in
in southern california they try to
invest their money
in this country what what what is going
and the answer of course is that the
united states of america is
a miracle and it needs to be cherished
and sustained
and nurtured in every way we can
people who come here i'm trying to think
back now ronald reagan didn't live to
see the kind of uncontrolled immigration
that we have witnessed since he left
office and so he was fundamentally
pretty relaxed about
immigration but what he always
understood what people of that
generation always understood
was that people come here to become
american
so the idea that it is in the interest
of certain politicians you and i i'm
sure could go off and do a whole show on
the problems with california this
spectacular state
so blessed in so many ways so beautiful
so filled with enterprising and talented
people
and the homeless and yes okay
the problem with california is the
government of california
in whose interest it now is to colonize
certain
groups or communities of people when
they come here for political purposes
and try to trap them in a certain kind
of mindset
instead of permitting them to enter into
the fullness of american life that's
just wrong
it is just wrong so the answer is yes i
do believe we have enough in common
we have our ideals we have american
history
the resources of american history from
the revolutionary war where you see
it seems providential the way washington
is able to
escape from brooklyn across to manhattan
the wind blows it the right way at just
the right time
the courage to stand up to what was then
the greatest empire on earth
the civil war lincoln this
martyr in giving his life
to hold the union together and to
abolish slavery
the greatest generation in the second
world war i would argue
that the cold war which is a bipartisan
project it begins with harry truman
it ends with ron with george h.w bush
and in between intellectuals behave
by and large pretty badly really during
the cold war but it's ordinary american
people who continue to vote
to sustain the politicians who want to
spend the money to do what we need to do
that this country is able to sustain
that kind of a project
across four and a half years four and a
half decades rather
until communism collapses and the soviet
by the way this is this pet peeve of
mine it is now
we're not allowed to say that our side
won the cold war it just ended
nobody won nobody lost it just ended
well let me point out one thing
the united states is still here and the
soviet union went defunct
we won so the resources of american
history the ideals that we have
the ability the this is well your book
on western the the right side of history
the astonishing thing about the western
civilization is not that it's western
it's that it it consists of permanent
truths which are open to
anyone from anywhere and the greatest
exemplar of that tradition
in the world today is the united states
yes of course we have enough resources
if we choose to sustain them
longtime friend of the show senator
presidential candidate and host of the
podcast verdict with ted cruz
it's ted cruz from 2003 to 2008
senator cruz served as the solicitor
general of texas essentially
hired to handle appeals involving the
state from a constitutionalist
perspective
he argued before the supreme court of
the united states nine times winning
five of those cases
cruz was then elected as a u.s senator
from texas the senator first became
widely popular in 2013
when he gave a 21-hour speech on the
senate floor to hold up a federal budget
bill in order to defund
obamacare it led to a government
shutdown and ruffled a lot of feathers
but it also showed supporters that
senator cruz was committed to walk the
walk of a conservative political leader
you can hear him tell this story in the
full episode cruz joined us and gave his
perspective on being raised by a father
who fled communist cuba in the 50s
in regards to america's size of
government and its control and the
ever-growing sentiments with regard to
socialism
senator cruz's story hits home on the
need to fight against tyranny
when we let senator cruz know that he
was going to be in this episode he sent
us
this letter this november the american
dream is very much at stake
as the precious rights and freedoms we
cherish are under assault by the radical
left
months ago following the horrific death
of george floyd thousands of americans
across the country exercised their first
amendment right
to peacefully protest against police
brutality and for equal justice
however these protests were hijacked by
violent antifa members
and other anti-american anarchists who
would arrive at protests with weapons
rocks commercial-grade lasers
sledgehammers and weapons-grade
fireworks
to use against the men and women of law
enforcement the very people who put
their lives on the line every day to
protect
our lives and rights this violence
should be universally condemned but
unfortunately
democrats have been largely silent
they've made a cynical political
decision
and believe it's politically expedient
to stand with the rioters i chaired a
hearing just a few weeks ago
not a single democrat who participated
in the hearing would criticize antifa
instead many democrats across the
country are actually supporting calls
from the violent mob to defund our
police departments
this is the face of the democrat party a
democrat party that refuses to condemn
antifa violence refuses to stand with
the men and women of law enforcement
and has bernie sanders running the show
that should scare every american
we need to stand for justice stand with
the men and women of law enforcement who
by and large engage in proper conduct
and stand for freedom that is how we
protect the american dream
that's from senator ted cruz full
disclosure i've been friends with
senator cruz for a very long time
i backed him in his original race
against david dewhurst then the
lieutenant governor
of the state of texas i've always found
senator cruz to be charming and fun
i know you don't always see that side of
ted but he really is quite fantastic
in episode 54 hear ted tell me about his
family and about how his community the
hispanic community is a fundamentally
conservative community but conservatives
need to communicate the message that
connects with them
[Music]
politics is my family story i mean look
all of us are products of our family
story
and and my dad uh as you know my dad
fought in the cuban revolution i mean
when he was a kid when he was a teenager
he was
fighting alongside fidel castro fighting
against batista who was a corrupt
dictator
and and was thrown in prison and he was
tortured
and and my dad came to to texas when he
was just 18.
and and i grew up as a kid hearing
stories hearing stories about being a
freedom fighter and it actually works
out
my father fought with caster didn't know
castro was a communist one anytime i
really want to
yank my father's chain i'll call him a
communist gorilla that drives him nuts
um what he knew was that batista was
corrupt he was in bed with the mob
you know godfather two you know that
whole i mean that was that was what it
was it was a completely corrupt
dictatorship
and the revolution as my dad describes
it we're a bunch of 14 and 15 year old
kids who didn't know any better
um my dad left in 57 and he fled cuba
because
batista's army was going to kill him
the revolution succeeds in 59 so 59
castro declares as a communist
begins seizing people's lands begins
executing dissidents
and my aunt mighty esonya i'm very close
to
she was still there she's my dad's kid
sister and she fought in the
counter-revolution she fought against
castro
she ended up being imprisoned and
tortured by castro's goons
and then she she ultimately fled cuba
two came to texas
and so my cousin bebe and i bibi is is
sonia's daughter
the two of us as kids we literally grew
up sitting at the feet of my dad and my
aunt
and listening to them tell stories of
fighting for freedom and
and that's what i've wanted to do my
whole life for as long as i can remember
since i was a little kid is is
in our house you know it wasn't that
politics was something you just kind of
read the paper
no that's interesting i mean there was
an urgency to it
it was having principled men and women
in office
that's how you protect yourself from
tyranny and and so that's what i wanted
to do
my whole life one of the things that's
been fascinating to me i'm from
california
the republican party has been
eviscerated among hispanic voters in
california
that is not what has happened in texas
in texas what is it a 55 45 or 60 40
split in favor of democrats but it's
certainly competitive
with republicans here at something like
80 20 uh in favor of democrats if that
it may be higher
uh so what has been done in texas what
have you done in your races to help draw
hispanic voters so look in
in texas in 2012 i got 40 of the
hispanic vote in 2018 i got 42 percent
of the hispanic vote and then and that
is despite
the the media demagoguing like crazy and
listen i think the hispanic
community is a fundamentally
conservative community
if you look at the values in our
community that resonate
faith family patriotism
hard work you know a friend of mine
years ago asked an interesting question
he said when's the last time you saw
an hispanic panhandler
i'm going to tell you i don't think i
ever have because frankly in hispanic
culture it would be seen as
shameful to be out there on the streets
begging
and yet you look at hard work individual
responsibility
and and those are conservative values
and you also look at
what unifies the hispanic community
which is the immigrant experience
coming to america seeking freedom that
is a message that resonates but i'll
tell you i had the exact same message
uh in the rio grande valley and
overwhelmingly hispanic communities that
i had in
deep east texas and and the message of
jobs and freedom and security that's a
message that resonates
look i think the hispanic community is a
conservative community but we've got to
respond to the needs and interests and
values in the hispanic community
if you look right now today we have the
lowest hispanic unemployment
ever recorded we've also got the lowest
african-american unemployment ever
recorded
now the clown show that is the
democratic 2020 primary none of them are
going to admit that they're going to go
to hispanics and african americans that
are seeing the lowest unemployment ever
recorded and they're going to say
these policies are terrible for you you
should go back to the obama era policies
where you had much higher unemployment
much higher poverty
that is nonsense let me give you one of
my favorite stats of the last two and a
half years
the last two and a half years five
million people came off of food stamps
five million and and look as republicans
we've got to be able to articulate that
and explain it in a way that that's not
just a
a number on a pie chart
those are five million real human beings
those are moms and dads
who two and a half years ago they were
dependent on the federal government for
their basic food needs
who now presumably they've gotten a job
they're coming home tonight
they're carrying a bag of groceries
they're setting it down on the kitchen
table
and those moms and dads are looking
their kids in the eyes they're having
the dignity
of work the self-respective work that is
what the american dream is all about
being able to provide for your family
achieve your dreams
but we've got to communicate and tell
you the hispanic community that is a
powerful message hispanics don't want to
be dependent on government and what
what what the socialists what the
democrats say is they
want them to be dependent on government
they want them to be a vassal dependent
state
vote for democrats and be trapped in
dependencies what i
what i know hispanics want is the
independence to chase their dreams
that is a conservative message
back in episode 13 we were joined by one
of the most influential writers of the
last half century david mamet
author of a variety of books plays and
films including glengarry glen ross
heist the untouchables and the academy
award nominated the verdict and wag the
dog
a rare outspoken conservative among the
mainstream culture and a critic of
communism and fascism
david grew up in chicago his parents
were first generation americans
he began writing well in high school and
college and then after graduating
worked any and every job in the city
this introduced him to what the actual
working middle class of chicago was like
in the 60s which refined his style and
even drew him towards projects like the
untouchables and one of his more recent
books
chicago sitting down with david mamet
was truly incredible really was an honor
he's a creative
eclectic guy and his view on the world's
command of language is just
incredible david mamet had to work to
stand on his own two feet
it paid off in a claim down the road
doing work he loved we'll be discussing
that here
but for starters listen to david debunk
the phrase's economic justice and social
justice
and discuss with me the dangers of
democratic socialism in american
government
[Music]
people on the left are constantly
suggesting that capitalism is this doggy
dog business
where people are attempting to tear each
other down and they use that as an
excuse for government interventionism
but it sounds like
you know your basic view of human beings
that all human beings are basically
at each other and that's why we have to
come to these basic agreements to leave
each other alone
well yeah i was watching yesterday that
the great tucker carlson i'm
crazy about him he had some cocka maybe
i think democrat something or other you
know
uh congressman or something like that
and he says to the the guy the democrat
he says wait a second he says you guys
got nothing left in a golf bag
so what in the world are you going to
run on in the midterms and the guy says
economic justice and social justice so i
said well okay
you know let's let's break it down to
the english language right
what does economic justice mean at the
end how's that different than justice
right it's communism what it means is uh
somewhat it's statism it means that
someone
is going to uh stand above
whatever rules we have for commerce and
decide what's just
to whom right so as you know tom soules
said once every ever anybody says
it's going to help a you say well who's
going to hurt right so economic justice
is uh at the end of the day it's
communism it's saying
and communism is someone's going to be
in charge of saying what you have to
give to me
and i'll i'll keep i'll keep what i
think
i want and give it back to you which
brings me back to
when i realized that the whole um the
the marxian idea from each according to
his ability to each according to his
need
really begs the question because the
term which is missing is
the state shall take from each according
to his ability which means the state's
going to determine what your ability is
the state shall give to each according
to his name
i'm the state i'm going to determine
what you need you don't determine it
anymore
you don't determine what your abilities
the state does so
so much for economic justice i thought
social justice how's that different than
decaf justice right regular common
garden decaf justice
right so justice is drawing a line
that's what justice is like
taking a line of type and justifying it
i'm going to say this is in
that's out is there going to be
injustice in terms of justice yeah sure
the talmud says right where there's law
there's injustice okay
great we're going to have a line right
social justice means there's no line
whoever's screaming loudest gets to say
this is what you have to do.
so you say wait a second let's refer to
the line let's refer to the law they say
no no
throw out that law the law is
insufficient and i got a guy talking to
it surely says well obviously the
constitution's out of date how would two
thousand a two hundred and thirty
forty year document possibly be relevant
i didn't wanna say well
why are we sitting here reading the
torah but
so what i said was wait a second okay
let's say it's out of date
how are you going to fix it what do you
suggest and more importantly what are
the rules
by which you suggest we're going to set
go about fixing it
because social justice is fascism that's
what it means it means that the group of
people who
screams the loudest gets to determine
what the law is and that always ends in
murder
so that's a they're two wonderful of
phrases economic justice and social
justice
which don't mean nothing mr samantha's
this would tell us
they mean something and what they what
the first thing they do is they're an
aesthetic
are you optimistic for the future of the
country or do you think that yeah i feel
incredible you know somebody said a long
time ago they said no a democracy
survives more than 300 years so i think
that this new
shift to a a constitutional republic
back toward
a constitutional constitutional republic
is going to
lengthen uh the viability of the
american experiment
by 50 to 100 years that's what i think
what do you think i mean i'm i'm a
little more pessimistic than you just
because i feel like the pendulum swings
pretty far in this country
and uh and it's swung from barack obama
to donald trump which means that it's
going to swing back even further to the
left the next time around just because
the democratic party by default
has made itself into a democratic
socialist party
kind of a european democratic socialist
party and so when the pendulum swings
it's going to swing back toward bernie
sanders or
alexandria ocasio-cortez at least
temporarily and that's not good for the
country i don't think that there are a
lot of
substantive conversations being had
because people are so angry at each
other
and i do think that has to do with the
lack of a common base of values like it
sounds like when you were growing up
you're growing up with the feeling that
despite all the corruption in chicago if
you worked hard you could get ahead and
it was actually your obligation as a
decent human being
to work hard and make something of
yourself and i feel like there
are entire generations of people in this
country who've been raised on the
premise
that america is actually a terrible
place that is seeking to put its boot on
your throat
and that anyone who proclaims that
america is good is a perpetuator of this
evil system
that's true but all these generations
who are raised in the bubble i don't
think starbucks can
can uh open outlets sufficiently
enough to keep pace with that growing
population
so what are they going to do for a
living after their parents diner you
know they're sitting on the couch and
working as a barista i don't get it well
that's the big question and i do wonder
you know whether these folks have a
skill set well they they don't i mean
that's the other thing that gets me
there's
and i talked i have a lot of kids i mean
i i want to go live in a shoe with the
old woman that's how many kids i have
but we we talk a lot and i talk to them
and
some of them experience the great joy of
doing something for a living
yeah i mean it's but i i i don't know
that there are that many
people in the united states who actually
see that i mean they see they see
there are too many people i and maybe
i'm the pessimist here but i see a lot
of people in the united states who see
work as something to be avoided like
they attribute all of their stress to
work work is always a bad thing when
they talk about things in their life
that they want to get over it's work and
you know for me my goal is to work until
i die because that's usually how it
works the minute you retire you're gone
right
so my uh yeah my belief is sort of the
belief from the from
the book of genesis which is that you
are put on the earth to cultivate it and
the minute you stop cultivating it
there's no reason for you to be here
anymore but i think that
there are a lot of people who actually
believe that they are put on here here
on earth for leisure time
and enjoyment and the more that we
require of you the harder you have to
work
that's an inherent flaw in the country
according to bernie sanders logic we're
so rich why should anybody have to work
well bernie
i think i met him in the old days
because i spent a lot of time about the
same age overlapping in north central
vermont i don't think he's ever worked a
day in his life
literally he he hasn't i mean he he was
kicked out of a commune for not working
enough when he was
legitimately it's an actual thing that
happened and now he owns a lake house
right so
yeah it's a great country where you can
never work a day in your life and have a
lake house where you vacation with bill
de blasio
well the question is where the question
is which the the young
won't address is where's the money come
from they say from the government well
all the government can do is is either
tax you or steal it from you
or waste it or spend money on either
things that
everybody needs but nobody wants to pay
for or things that nobody wants
those are the only two things the
government can spend the money on so the
young
person doesn't say where does the money
come from i mean what i worry about i'm
not sure that it's
that we have a problem of economics as
so much as you know a lot of folks on
the left thinks the problem of
redistributionism and the economic
system and all this i really don't think
that's the problem i think we do have a
problem of virtue and heart
i think i think there's a giant hole in
the middle of the american soul that has
been
carved there by 40 50 years of
dependence on government and a belief
that
there is no higher calling for you that
your your job on this earth is basically
to experience the most pleasure possible
and then die
uh and i don't know what replaces that
other than a return to some sort of
centralizing values
well i don't know either except that uh
i have a
difficult time controlling myself i mean
i want to even attempt to try to control
somebody else going to be what it's
going to be
oh yeah i mean i'm not talking about
compelling people but i do think that
the appeal of a moral lifestyle has
always been a hard sell
and it's it's a particularly hard cell
when there are no consequences to
immorality
well there's a very good book on the
subject you know which is called a torah
you know what's the consequences for
morality it's a it's a plague or 40
years in the desert or
i think twice about it let's talk a
little bit more about hard work and
skill sets with mike rowe
mike was host of the widely popular
reality series dirty jobs which as his
website puts it
transformed cable television into a
landscape of swamps sewers ice roads
coal mines oil derricks crab boats
hillbillies and lumberjack camps
today micro hosts the podcast the way i
heard it and the emmy-winning facebook
watch web series returning the favor
in which she travels the country
searching for remarkable people he also
runs the mike rowe works foundation
which awards scholarships to students
pursuing a career in the skilled trades
mike has made a business out of showing
us that hard work truly matters
talking with mike was a lot of fun his
personal experiences differ so much
from my own but his transformation from
sort of a news guy
into a voice for the working classes is
really an incredible story
and a reminder that so many americans
are doing the kind of hard work and jobs
that many of us don't hear about in our
daily lives
in episode 12 mike tells me about his
foundation's sweat pledge
skills and work ethic aren't taboo and
why some critics seem to hate it so much
and we discuss the politicization of the
skills gap and large opportunity in
america's workforce
the truth of which cuts against the
narrative pushed in politics and in the
[Music]
media
every job eventually becomes a job no
matter how passionate you are about your
initial belief in a job and i love my
job and i'm sure you love your job
eventually it gets to the point where
you got to get up this morning got to go
to work right so you're getting up and
going to work
happiness is a it's a
it's a terrific symptom
it's a terrible goal right
it's just a terrible goal because it's a
it's a sucker's bet
if it were if happiness were that
tangible then every then the same thing
would make everyone happy
but obviously it it doesn't you know but
i just i i'm sure of that
i'm not sure of much but i'm i'm sure of
that i wrote this thing you'd get a kick
out of it it's a
it started like most everything i do as
an attempt to uh
amuse myself but after a bottle of wine
one night you know
my foundation awards work ethic
scholarships
so we need to have some mechanism
by which we can try to account
for workout i mean how do you measure
character it's virtually impossible
but i wrote this thing called a sweat
pledge skills and work ethic
are not taboo aren't taboo sweat right
and you have to sign it it's a 12
point pledge sort of part 12 step
process part
scout law right and um
and some people really really really
hate it but one of the first things is
you know you know i'm i'm grateful
i won the greatest lottery of all time i
i live in america
two i do not follow my passion
right at three i mean it goes down all
of these things it was just
it was like a little personal manifesto
for me
uh but i only bring it up because
it's become increasingly more important
to my foundation
and now the more i look back on it it's
hysterical ben
how how outraged people get
i give away maybe five million dollars
so far
right not a ton by foundation standards
but it's a challenge money yeah
every year about eight hundred thousand
dollars goes out
and um every year people say well why do
i have to sign
the sweat pledge and i said well you
don't have to
it's entirely possible this particular
pile of free money might not be for you
[Laughter]
what do you mean i'm like well i mean
there are many scholarship funds that
award academic achievement
i'm more interested in in awarding
attendance right
i mean athletic achievement talent there
there are all kinds of rubrics and
metrics for measuring
value but where's the work ethic so
that's what we try and do
and forgive me i'm trying to bring this
back to the answer to the question you
posed but i've forgotten what it is
again so i mean that's like you took me
on the journey and now now we're left to
drift here but i'm gonna
do a sweat pledge i'm gonna send you a
sweat pledge man okay sounds good well
and let's latonia not in for a second
the first principle that you mentioned
which is that
you won the lottery because you live
here which is something with which i
totally agree but that's a pretty
controversial proposition these days
sure and
it's it's become almost partially a
left-right proposition unfortunately
uh where you see there's a poll that
came out just within the last month
that suggested that republicans
particularly were very proud to be
members
of the united states very proud to be
american and they were very proud to be
american when obama was president this
was not dependent on who was president
it was
73 percent of americans were republicans
were proud when obama was present it's
now and for democrats was like 54 were
positive when it was obama and now it's
like 38
because of president trump why do you
think there are so many people
in the country who look at the situation
that they've been handed which is the
freest most prosperous country in the
history of humanity
and and think to themselves i'm a victim
in this scenario
and that not to discount anybody's
actual hardships are passed but
why do you think that that's become such
a prominent thing and what clearly is a
land of opportunity
because it's not clear it's not clearly
right the big
of all the divides the one that worries
me the most
is the divide between people who are
genuinely
genuinely convinced that opportunity is
dead
and those who are not right the ones who
are
artificially convinced or just you know
paying lip service to it
they don't matter but there are a lot of
people who really and truly
truly believe the system is rigged and
they truly believe opportunity is dead
uh that's a they scare me
um not because i'm frightened of them
but because that belief
is that that'll kill us
i mean if that belief really truly
spreads it'll kill us this is why the
skills gap becomes weirdly political
it's it shouldn't be it's just
opportunity it's just 6.3 million jobs
sitting there vacant
but when i point that out it's it's very
difficult
because everything is politicized today
right it's what comes back is well
what does the existence of opportunity
mean
in a country where we're fighting over
the fact that opportunity may or may not
be dead
it's proof positive that it's not now
that's a problem
right the optics don't line up so then
you have economic experts with whom i i
really can't engage because i'm not an
economist
but they will tell you why the skills
gap is a myth
so here's how it breaks down if i point
to six million available jobs
my friends on the right will tell me
that those jobs are available because
human beings are fundamentally lazy my
friends on the left
will tell me that those jobs are
available because employers are
fundamentally
greedy and that's where we are we
can't think beyond the fact that our
basic
philosophies require us to see humanity
as either lazy
or greedy now the truth is in my opinion
we're both lazy and greedy right
and we're neither lazy nor greedy
we're all of it and none of it and all
of it gets
measured out in unequal amounts but we
don't
we don't have time today to parse
the nuance of that it simply has to be
one or the other
so when i post a picture of me uh
standing next to the flag on the 4th of
july
i get a lot of pushback and i think a
lot of people who
are pushing me back don't really want to
push back they just don't want
to see me doing something patriotic
because the lines have been drawn and
now
if you're if you're patriotic well then
you must be on the right
that's also really super dangerous it's
a it's a false choice
and and we have to push back against
that
we it's incumbent upon us
i think you're doing a decent job of it
i'll try it thanks
i mean no honestly look you're as biased
as i am
yours bias is the next person but you
can point these cameras
at anything you want and you're you're
pointing them at
honest thoughtful conversation
long-time television personality
commentator and emmy award-winning
journalist john stossel
has spent his career espousing the
virtues of individual freedom
and exposing the evil of big government
john is hosted and anchored for abc news
including good morning america and 2020
as well as fox business he wanted to
bring his message to younger audiences
so he left that show to now produce for
his own youtube channel where he
releases a video every week presenting
the case that good things happen in free
markets and under a smaller government
talking with john was a lot of fun i've
been following john's career since i was
very young i've read a lot of his books
and honestly his view on libertarianism
has really affected
my own and shaped how i think about the
size and role of government in episode
27 john walks through how his
media and journalism career made him
hyper aware of the shortcomings of
government
particularly in making life better for
americans we also discussed the
countries that the left points to in
regards to democratic socialism
functioning well
and how the biggest capitalists in the
country sometimes become capitalism's
biggest enemies
[Music]
i just wanted to cover something that
other people weren't covering so
the time all people did was politics the
weather
crime disasters that was news
i thought there's consumer issues out
there
psychology medicine companies are
ripping people off i'll do that
and i did that and won 19 emmy awards
bashing
business but i gradually watched
the regulation that i was calling for
and often getting sometimes politicians
would say that was great we're going to
pass a law and fix that
in oregon they created a department of
consumer affairs but then i'd go back
and do the same
story we'd send a tv set out to 20
repair shops and
18 with a loose part 18 would say oh
loose part no charge
two would rip us off i'd go back and say
would you ever do this
oh no yeah well watch this play the
videotape
and it was great television bashing
business but
then so we'd do it again now there's a
department of consumer affairs the
results are the same most people are
honest
a few cheat so what's the department of
consumer affairs doing
they have a big dreary room with a bunch
of
dreary people at desks filling out forms
now you have to get a license to be tv
repairmen
and supposedly that will screen out the
bad guys but
it doesn't it just lets in the ones who
are sophisticated enough
to know how to get the license the
immigrant maybe
works under beyond the law in the black
market
everybody has to pay a few pennies more
to pay for the lawyers and consumers
know better off
so i started reading more um i didn't
love the conservative press
because it looked like your people
wanted to to police the bedroom
and police the rest of the world and i
didn't like that
and i discovered reason magazine and
that was an epiphany oh my god these
people get it better than i do
and i became a libertarian coming out of
princeton i was going oh yes we know how
to solve poverty my professors said
it's an outrage in this rich country
that some people are poor
but then i watch these programs fail
they just teach
people to be dependent and if you look
at the graph i
have used this in my videos of the war
on poverty and the poverty line the war
in poverty
began and the poverty rate dropped for
seven years
and after that it's gone up and down
improvement stopped because the
government teaches people to be
dependent if you've got a man in the
house your check goes down
and then most interesting look at the
chart from before the war in poverty
the slope of the line was about the same
americans were lifting themselves
out of poverty the war on poverty
trillions of dollars
continued progress for five years and
then stopped it
so what do you make of the new kind of
left argument with regard to the
countries they admire so for a long time
for decades the soviet union was a place
where they were kind of interested in
the experiment and then
for a little while they were interested
in hugo chavez and they were interested
in cuba for a while but now
the the modern iteration of the of the
socialist movement
is in favor of social democracy so they
like norway they like sweden uh they
like the nordic countries this is the
one that
bernie sanders likes to trot out all the
time what do you make of the argument
that those countries are
cohesive that they are functioning well
that they have high standards of living
and they also have massive governmental
burdens that are driven by
enormous regulations and tax rates
well first of all they're not really
socialists in the denmark prime minister
went on tv to say
look we're a market economy we're not
socialist government
does not control the means of production
and that's the most important thing
scandinavian countries don't even have a
government minimum wage
they do have a big welfare state and
they can afford that because they have a
homogeneous culture and they have a
fairly free private market to pay for it
and the
economic freedom indexes they come out
ahead of the united states i don't know
how bernie calls them
socialists
do they innovate do they produce
anything
is it an accident that facebook google
and all these exciting wealth creating
companies
your podcasts have come out of silicon
valley and
california places far away from
washington dc
i don't think so yeah and that i think
is is always the big distinction that
folks fail to make they that socialism
freezes things in place and
redistributes them and capitalism
generates
new and innovative innovative methods
but
when it comes to things like healthcare
where the left really is putting its
heavy focus these days what they say is
okay well fine so we sacrificed a little
bit of innovation but there's an entire
group of people who have pre-existing
conditions
and they don't have a capacity to pay
for the health care that they need
so what's the best system for providing
health care if we're not going to
have some sort of baseline government
provided healthcare
it would be presumptuous for me to say
what the best system is but what i've
learned
is that the more market there is the
better
and poor people with a pre-existing
condition are not going to have a market
solution
but we have in america medicaid for poor
people
medicare for us old people and no
hospital emergency room turns away any
poor person
we don't really have a free market
system because the rest of it is paid
for not by individuals but
by insurance companies or governments so
what really works is when you go to the
doctor and you say
gee doc does it really have to cost 200
bucks i'm paying for this myself
and this is starting to happen with the
health savings accounts
your company instead of just having the
insurance company pay for it they give
you some money
and you make some of those decisions and
doctors often say
really you're paying paying yourself
like
now i don't have to wait two months for
the insurance company
okay well a hundred dollars and then
they don't even know where to put it
because they haven't had a cash box for
so long
but moving toward more consumer driven
and that means high deductibles which
nobody wants to hear about everybody
hates that
that's the only answer and bernie
single pay in europe you don't pay for
anything that's true in england
uh forget about norway england canada
australia and it's true
you don't pay but the national health
service in england was
created the year i was born and in some
cases they still use that kind of
technology because
innovation stops in government you just
do
you don't get in trouble if you do what
you did before
you know most young people won't read
books that's why i'm making videos
you mentioned tucker i i just released a
video
on amazon and jeff bezos and it was
i started it with a video defending
bezos against bernie saying how dare
bernie attacked this man who yes he's
the richest man in the world but he's
made us
all richer by lowering prices so much
the fed even lowered its inflation rate
and they pay vast amounts in taxes and
their investors pay
lots of money in taxes he's good for
america and he's being trashed
but i'm midway through writing this
piece and bezos caves in to the
progressives and says yeah i'm going to
raise all my workers to 15 bucks an hour
cutting off performance bonuses stupidly
perhaps
um still it's his company he can do that
he'll find very good workers for that
but then he goes on and says i'm going
to lobby
like another craven opportunist rather
than a capitalist
i'm going to lobby government to force
every company to pay 15
to get rid of the competitive advantage
my competitors would have
and since i got lots of robots replacing
workers i'm going to really crush these
guys if they have to pay 15 bucks an
hour
capitalism's biggest enemies are often
capitalists
yeah and this is i think a great point
that libertarians i wish would make more
often because
the kind of pie in the sky rosy view of
free markets is always the people are
going to act morally within free markets
but the truth is they're a bunch of
people as long as there's a big
government capacity out there who are
going to take advantage of that this is
why when folks say well big business is
is capitalist like have you been
watching big business maybe watching any
business
human beings are willing to take
advantage of each other which is why
you do need and i always i keep coming
back to this and i think that this is
the
and not to not to promote my own
ideology but i'm going to because my
show
that you do need a tremendous focus on
bringing up virtuous people in a free
system if the free system is going to
last because
otherwise people are just going to try
and pervert
the the system for their own ends which
is exactly what you're talking about
with bezos and
when people say crony capitalism that's
not crony capitalism that's economic
fascism it's exactly the same sort of
state-sponsored monopolism that you were
seeing in
in early you know post-weimar germany
so it's it's it's really um
i think it's necessary for libertarians
and i include myself in this number
to spend an awful lot of time teaching
people that that virtue is necessary
uh and that's why you know it's the
markets are great but this is where this
is
where i think adam smith differs from
the the lord mandeville
bees metaphor right adam smith
recognizes i don't know the lord
so there's a very famous um
there was a track that was written right
before adam smith uh all about
uh i forget the name of the the tract by
uh it was written by mandeville and it
was basically the
it's a piece of poetry it's like 500
lines about the
economy of the bees and his basic idea
is that economies develop
because people have vices private vices
become public virtues
in other words you want to buy a nice
piece of jewelry
and therefore this creates economic
growth because you want something that
you didn't have before
and maybe it's coming from selfishness
or greed right it's sort of an objection
by watching it as a device
so my wanting it would be the vice in
this particular in this particular
scenario
but what adam smith says and he's
correct
is that while that's true with regard to
vices that are not inherently damaging
to the system they're vices that are
inherently damaging to the system and so
we have to teach people
that freedom can only be preserved by
people who actually spend
an awful lot of time thinking about
virtue well that's bigger than i can
i can digest or put into one of my
five-minute videos yeah well
let's talk about for a second the the
changes that it's
hard for a bezos to resist he's almost
not doing duty to his shareholders
when there's this monster government
over here doling out f you have
put your headquarters here i'll give you
a tax break
in some ways he'd be a fool not to ask
for it the only
solution is to shrink the state and why
did japan and germany do so well
after world war ii because we bombed
them the smithereens and they had to
start over
and they got rid of all the guilds and
the special interests that were holding
progress back and then they grew
so fast it's a horrible poorly
depressing idea to say that's the only
way to stop the growth of government
but maybe it is well i'm not going to go
to bombing play but people smithereens
i'm just saying you keep asking me how
do we convince people
can we teach virtue and i don't know
that you can
there's perhaps no one who proclaims the
glory of capitalism more than radio host
and financial guru dave ramsey
as a best-selling author of multiple
books including the widely popular book
the total money makeover the host of a
nationally syndicated radio show and
podcast the dave ramsey show
and the creator of classes in training
like financial peace university
dave ramsey is a figure of eliminating
debt and reaching financial prosperity
having had great successes now without
hardship in the business world dave now
spends his time passing on the knowledge
he has acquired as a proponent of
personal responsibility to achieve
personal success
meeting dave was really awesome i know
so many people who have turned their
lives around
because they followed dave's steps to
success his
realistic view of human nature and his
reality-based view
that you have to take personal
responsible decisions rather than
blaming the system
is a refreshing one in this particularly
system-based
thinking time in episode 36 of the show
dave and i discussed the myth of
cheating your way to the top in business
and other victim mentalities
the data on life choices that lead to
success and how wealth equality is
actually not fair
when it comes to kind of personal
character how much do you think that
financial decisions are about
education of people to make the right
decisions and how much is it about
actually being able to put off
what you want for what you need now
that's called maturity
the ability to delay pleasure and um
that is a character quality
integrity there's a high correlation
between integrity
wholeness not just telling the truth and
honesty but this
full-on integrity you are who you are
all the time that's integrity
and not only do you tell the truth not
only do you honor your word in
situations
high data point correlation between that
and the ability to build wealth
this idea that you cheat your way to the
top is mythology
it truly does not work out there i mean
think about it if you go to the local uh
car place and get your car worked on he
cheats you you tell everybody you know
and you don't tell everybody you know
and if you go in there and he says oh
it was 35 cents i fixed it don't worry
about it you tell everybody you know
because you just found a unicorn
you know what i mean so where the guy
just did the right thing and and you
you send your family your friends and
that's how you succeed in business
is you do the right thing it's how you
succeed in life you do the right thing
integrity the ability to delay pleasure
the ability to say
you know i'm going to give up something
today i'm going to live like no one else
so that later i can live and give like
no one else that's the way we say it on
the show
yeah one of the things that i think is
so fascinating about your approach is
that it is
an approach that is driven by personal
responsibility so much of what's going
on
in the country in politics generally is
driven by precisely the opposite
attitude so
you're smart you stay away from politics
i'm in politics full-time and it seems
like politicians
make bank off of basically telling
people that nothing they do is their
own responsibility and that everything
that is wrong in their life can be
blamed on
outside forces in america how much of
people
how much of of what's bad in people's
lives do you think can generally be
blamed
on the decisions they make and how much
can be blamed on on outside forces if
you had to balance that out
well i i think you can be born into a
situation
where um you don't
you know you you're i grew up in a
neighborhood where people said stuff
like the little man can't get ahead
it was a victim mentality blue collar
thing it's like
you know the the union will take care of
you the government will take care of you
i sure hope we can elect a
you know a president or congressman will
take care of us because the little man
just can't get ahead on his own
and and is is that a reality yeah if you
think it is
if you think you can or you think you
can't you're right henry ford said you
know and so
there's a reality to this and so the
belief is the real privilege
it's not the skin color and it's not the
socio-economic thing it's the belief in
the culture you come out of
i mean i grew up in tennessee and uh
where hillbilly culture
my family scotch-irish and proud
hillbillies uh of the best
of the best kind and an interesting
bunch they'll fight you uh for their
freedoms
and yet sometimes they'll adopt that
victim mentality
and a whole bunch of those folks um i
mean
jd did a nice book hillbilly elegy that
indicated that probably that's
a bunch of us who elected trump but it
was all that
he was a little bit reagan-esque in that
it's up to you
i'll just make it where you can win you
know i'll do it for you
and there's a different message there in
that ideology but you know the problem
is if you start to believe someone else
is going to fix your life whoever it is
your employer your mommy the president
the congress you're screwed
yeah well this is one of the things i
really fear because i am seeing it rise
on both the left and the right there's a
sort of new right-wing populist movement
that suggests
okay well you know all the problems that
you're having life you didn't get
married because you couldn't afford it
and it's like well
maybe you should have made some
different decisions and single
motherhood is not a financial decision
it's not that you got pregnant out of
wedlock because you couldn't afford it
the classic studies are that 97
of the 30 year olds that graduated from
school
high school before they got married and
got married before they had a kid
that's all they did high school and they
did it in the right order in other words
97 are above the poverty level
almost everyone below the poverty level
somehow got that out of order
they got pregnant before they got out of
school they got pregnant before got
married they got married before they got
out of school they got it out of order
it's the success order all kinds of data
points on that statistical evidence
and it's not a political statement it's
just this is the proper way to live your
life
turns out morals have implication
characters
character has implications i fully agree
with this i think that the
the supposed crisis that we're having in
terms of happiness the rise in
the opioid epidemic although some of
that is due to bad diagnoses and people
being given
medical opioids and all of that the rise
in suicide the rise in single motherhood
that in the end these are mostly
personal problems these are people
making bad decisions
and they're making bad decisions because
they've been taught by society by
the government by the culture that if
you make a bad decision it's not really
your fault and the beginning of wisdom
is recognizing that it's probably
your fault where do you think these kind
of where did things start to fall apart
or do you think things are really not
that falling apart
you know it's strange i i there's
pockets that are falling apart
and there's sometimes a malaise that's
or a fog over some things but then
there's entire
segments of the population they're
booming like never before they're in the
best years of their life right now
um and maybe did even under obama you
know they had the best years of their
life
and and but i mean we share a book in
our faiths and my christian faith
through jewish faith the
book of proverbs the book of wisdom and
all throughout the book of wisdom the
fool
is juxtaposed with the wise the wise
does this the fool does this
the wisdom is this and wisdom is in the
hebrew
you know this probably is the art of
living
life well is really what it means and
that's what we've lost
is wisdom not knowledge but we've lost
wisdom as juxtaposed with a fool and
and if you read through proverbs you go
well i've done that i'm a fool
i've done that so i'm gonna quit doing
that some will be wise in the house of
the wise
are stores of choice food and oil but a
foolish man devours all he has
if you spend everything you make you're
a fool fool i've done that
and then when i quit doing that i
actually saved money i had some money
in the house of the wives i mean it was
just it's remarkable isn't it
and so the art of living life well and
when you start to believe that if i
uh plant corn i'm going to get corn if
i'm going to reap what i sow if i'm
going to live in a cause and effect
world where i actually
can impact my own destiny there's
variables around me there's isms
i mean there's racism and sexism and
baldism
there are people that won't let me do
stuff because i'm bald i hadn't been a
bald president
elected since television go look that
one up it's interesting
so i mean but i mean you know these
kinds of things are very we got one with
bat hair but we
don't have any with no hair you know i
mean and so jerry ford is not elected
but there's always you know i've got a
southern drawl
and for years in the radio business now
we've got 600 stations but for years
people in boston thought we broadcast
from a double-wide because we're in
tennessee
you know with no shoes you know i mean
there's all these isms right there's
everybody's got an ism they got to bust
through
i don't care who you are but if you
truly believe because of your ism
whatever it is that you can't win you're
not going to get corn if you plant corn
then why would you ever plant corn
that's hopelessness
and and that's the the path of the fool
yeah the way that i've put it on my own
show is that
i root for reality because there's
nothing else to root for
there's a lot of folks out there who are
rooting against reality and you see this
not only in politics we see it in
culture just the general thing where
people look at their life and they go
exercise and fair here's a person who's
really rich and i'm not really rich and
that's unfair and you see politicians
say this without any solution they just
sort of
put it out there and this is their
actual talking point you say okay well
let's assume for a second that that is
unfair that if you were god you would
even all that out
you're not god you're not evening all
that out and even if you would even all
that out it wouldn't result exactly in
what you want here so
maybe you should stop fighting reality
and deal with reality instead
you know actually wealth equality is
unfair
because effort is not equal smarts is
not equal
i'm not as smart as bill gates he's
helped more people than i've helped
and as a result he has more money i mean
i haven't changed the world with a
computer he did
i'm not steve jobs i didn't do that now
i've made
a good bit of money i've helped a whole
bunch of people um but you know i was
arguing with this
lady a liberal lady and she was mad at
me because i had made a lot of money
selling books to people helping them
with money and she's like well you're
taking advantage of all these people
that are broke and i said
you know when i when i sold five books
for ten dollars nobody was mad
but all you people got pissed off when i
sold 10 million of them
and i helped 10 million people and so
the you know
your level of return is the level of
help and so that that just defeats the
wealth equality argument completely
because we now know that 79
of the millionaires in america today 8
out of 10 inherited
zero zero which means they did
something in the marketplace so the
american dream is alive and well i mean
one of the things that i love about your
show is that you actually do defend the
morality of of
the free market and that's something
that very few people are willing to do
in this day and age
it's all about the shortcomings of the
free market income inequality the idea
that people are being exploited and it
seems like they're coming from this
perspective
that even basic elements of life
in the intelligent gaps that this should
be somehow rectified
and you see this with they'll use bill
gates as an example how is there a bill
gates in this country who's worth this
much money and then you'll see somebody
who's worth no money
and you know you say well he's
contributed more he's he's
and they say well but that wasn't his
choice he was smarter right he was
smarter
he grew up better how do you answer that
well he did
you know he and he is and you know
george clooney's prettier than me so i
mean so what
deal with it i mean you did this is your
hand play your hand
and um you know i was on a we had a
leadership event we did our entree
leadership event last summer and
got to spend some time with condoleezza
rice and she
grew up in a in a segregated
neighborhood outside of birmingham
and she's she was talking about coming
out of that segregated neighborhood to
become secretary of state she's
brilliant and uh brilliant lady
and she said my parents told me my whole
life it doesn't matter where where i'm
coming from and what matters where
you're going
and you just decide that's what we're
going to do but that has
all this all the way back to do with
this thing called hope and this
belief that if i plant corn i shouldn't
be shocked if i get corn
if i plant nothing i can't gripe about
the farmer who planted corn
and was out there toiling to kill the
weeds and in the hot sun
meanwhile i'm standing over here
watching the guy and then i go well it's
not fair that he's got some corn
i mean i wonder if some of the
complaints that are cropping up
particularly among young people and i
speak a lot on college campuses where
there are a lot of young people who
make exactly these complaints that this
is coming as the result of a breakdown
in religious community because
i'm a religious person you're a
religious person there are a lot of rich
people
people who have been you know i've been
a lot poorer i've been
i've done well that's changed but i've
watched the same thing happen to people
in my community who i grew up with and
so i know all of them and so it's hard
to be a lot it's a lot harder to be
jealous of the guy that you've known and
grown up with
and he can go to for help than some
random guy on the street we have no
association with and as we fragment as a
community
there's more of a feeling of well maybe
that guy owes me money as opposed to
well i've known my next door neighbor my
entire life we go to the same church or
the same synagogue
the one area of equality that matters
more than any we are equal which is we
are all equal before god right god sees
us all exactly the same
with that breakdown i'm wondering if
maybe that's what's caused a lot of the
feeling of dispossession
well and and it's also you know
contributes to racism
also contributes to um arguments between
religion
i mean if you sit down and spend time
with people and actually develop a
relationship with people that have
different situation than you've got
you're going to learn there's good
people
and there's bad people and almost every
one of those things i know wealthy
people
all over the world they're worth
hundreds of million dollars there's some
of the best people on the planet
and i know some of them will cut your
throat just to see just to see if you
bleed
i mean and i know some poor people that
are some of the best people on the
planet and i know some of them will cut
your throat having anything to do with
the money
it's got to do with their character or
their lack of it the money just revealed
it
if you've enjoyed hearing from our past
guests in this collection be sure to
check out their full episodes and hear
more of the conversation
links to those are in our description
this is the last collection of great
moments from the sunday special we're
bringing you
we will see you here again in two weeks
with brand new episodes of the sunday
special
we're super excited for our upcoming
guests i think you're gonna like them
we'll see you here next time
[Music]
the ben shapiro show sunday special is
produced by mathis glover
executive producer jeremy boring
associate producer katie swinnerton
our guests are booked by caitlin maynard
post production is supervised by alex
ingaro
editing is by jim nicholl audio is mixed
by mike coromina
hair and makeup is by nico geneva title
graphics are by cynthia angulo the ben
shapiro show sunday special is a daily
wire
production copyright daily wire 2020.